The story of an actor on
a hit TV show,
a member of the Church of Scientology
and three former church members
who say he raped them.
Danny Masterson,
best known for his role
as Steven Hyde
on that 70 show,
which aired on Fox
for eight seasons, ending in 2006.
Now 47, Masterson was convicted in
May of raping two women
at his home
in separate incidents
between 2001 and 2003.
The jury deadlocked on the rape charge
involving the third woman on Thursday.
Yesterday, Masterson,
who continues to deny
the allegations, was sentenced to prison.
30 years to life.
Masterson's attorney
say he will appeal the convictions
but there is more to this story.
Questions about the role
of the Church of Scientology
and whether it played any role
in why
justice was so long
in coming in this case.
Scientology, a
relatively new religion, is secretive
and litigious
and has regularly found
its legitimate challenge,
including opposition
from the medical community to its claims
about mental
health and e meters devices
that supposedly monitor
the body's electric flow.
While so-called auditors
ask would be members
questions to discover sources of trauma.
The Scientology connection
is important here because,
as Rolling
Stone reported,
witnesses testified at the trial
that Scientology
has an expressly written doctrine
that not only discourages
but prohibits its members
from reporting one
another to law enforcement.
Now, during their testimony
and at the sentencing,
as well as in separate civil lawsuits,
Masterson's accusers said
that church officials
tried to silence them
and cover up for Danny Masterson.
During the trial,
Variety reported
that the women claimed, quote,
The church dissuaded them
from reporting Masterson to the police.
Prosecutors argued throughout the trial
that Masterson had taken advantage
of his position in the church
to rape women
without fear of repercussion,
and that the church forbid women
from going to the police
to report sexual assault, unquote.
The Los Angeles Times says
during closing arguments,
prosecutor Ariel
Manson told the jury, quote,
The church tells
his victims rape isn't rape.
You caused this.
And above all,
you can't go to law enforcement, unquote.
Hours after Masterson
sentencing, the Church of Scientology
responded by rereleasing its statement
from the day of his conviction in May.
It says in part,
There's not a scintilla of evidence
supporting the scandalous allegations
that the church harassed the accusers.
The church has no policy prohibiting
or discouraging members
from reporting criminal conduct
of anyone, unquote.
Among those in the courtroom yesterday
to support the women,
actress and advocate
Leah Remini, a former member
of the Church of Scientology
who has been an outspoken critic.
She joins us now
with Mike Render,
a former Church of Scientology
senior executive
and remedies co-host, of the podcast
Fair Game.
Thanks to both of you for being here.
Leah, let me start with you.
Variety reports
that one of the accusers identified
as Jane Doe number one testified, quote,
My understanding from Scientology
my entire life was
that you can never be a victim.
Nothing ever happens to you
that you didn't
cause no matter what condition
you find yourself in life,
no matter how horrible
you are
responsible, you created that, unquote.
Do you see Scientology itself on
trial here in any way?
Well, it's not
well, it should be on trial.
They should have been a codefendant
in this case.
Yes.
Scientology policy is
should be looked at.
Unfortunately, they have tax exemption.
But however,
this is absolutely true.
It's absolutely law.
It's absolutely policy of Scientology.
I was a Scientologist most of my life.
And Mike,
the former
head of the Office of Special Affairs,
And that is not her understanding.
That is the law of Scientology.
We are not allowed to report crimes
to the authorities.
We're not allowed to sue each other.
So that's absolute law.
And when you watched the trial, Leah,
what was that experience like?
It was heartbreaking.
I've been involved
supporting the Jane Doe as well, Mike,
for seven years.
I've had my own experiences with it.
This is one story out of thousands.
If not,
I mean,
I don't want to
anybody think
I'm being
you know,
I'm exaggerating for for any reason.
But to tell the truth, however,
this is just one of many cases
that Scientology has been involved
in, in attempting to obstruct justice.
And Mike, could also speak to that.
But it's the absolute
policy of Scientology. And
I think they should be held accountable,
which is some of the basis of my lawsuit,
so that people can come forward,
victims can come forward,
people are allowed to
report crimes concerning Scientologists,
sue members, as well as,
you know, civilian Scientologists.
People should not be in fear
of retaliation.
For a multi billion
dollar organization calling itself
the church
for fear of what they do to people